negli altri ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo io sono felice e non ci siamo su
un video particolare sta impazzando un
sacco in rete sta cosa diventi cose che
non crede viventi cose assurde 20 cose
che mi ha fatto mia nonna l'altro giorno
escono e volevo fare un video del genere
volevo fare tipo 20 foto scattate al
momento giusto tutti quegli scatti
caricano precisamente quando devono
arrivare in scene particolari faranno i
venti in questo caso sarebbe riduttivo
perché ci sono tante cose da trattare in
questo video visti solo un paio però era
talmente figo che ho detto devo farci un
video sopra quindi le guardiamo insieme
leggero anche i commenti che verranno
messi sotto ste foto che lo geniali
quindi ragazzi ecco a voi le foto
scattate al momento giusto
la prima è qua alquanto strana perché
c'è statista qua che sembra che sia
toccando la patata a quest'altra tizia è
in realtà ci ho messo un po a capirla e
questa però in realtà il braccio non è
di questa qui ma il braccio e di questa
ma anche te che fai la foto ma santiddio
ma diglielo che c'è al braccio che
sembra il suo e ho capito che te stai
arrapa però come contenta ma passiamo
altre ragazze che questa stranissima
pesa bellissima perché tipo sembra
troppo il culo della tipa dietro va
invece il braccio di quest'uomo che non
è proprio una tipa è la cosa più bella
della foto non è neanche questa ma
quanto è figo quello c'è il tifo che
invece sta cercando chi cazzo gli ha
[ __ ] la maglietta avrebbe lissimo è
tutto bello tranne il culo fantastico
andiamo avanti ragazzi con la prossima
io io io qua ci sono una domanda ma dopo
una ma che cazzo stava pensando il tizio
che ha fatto questa cosa che cosa stai
pensando di fare passiamo alla prossima
ragazzi questa anche raffica bello
gli dico la verità quando vado in bici
ciò sempre su terrori io non mi è mai
successo grazie a dio tocca ferro tocca
palle tocca tombino senti zia pro
compratele delle ciabatte nuove perché
caccia e quella roba lì next one is his
bellissima re posso fare una domanda che
il tizio nella foto come c'è finita in
questa posizione lasciamo stare il gatto
che fa karate kid è stupendo è
bellissimo quando sei in ritardo per la
telecronaca e porco il tachimetro
parcheggi in tribuna suggeriscono dagli
spalti
sì la tipa questa non la commento
lasciamo perdere
a me questa questa stupenda cioè non ho
parole ma per quale motivo mi spieghi il
t allora il tizio che già sta faccia che
tutto un dire l'espressione che cosa
pensava quando ha lanciato cane tipo che
fosse un pokémon non lo so fufi scelgo
te non puoi fare queste cose coi cani
santo iddio the next one
ecco qua è il cane che si prende la
rivincita su snow relax
passiamo alla prossima che invece a o
bella questa un oggetto non identificato
che vola sopra le campagne della toscana
nessuno se ne accorge
no vabbè questa foto è la [ __ ] vita
c'è un motivo se vi dicono tenetevi
saldamente alle prese non alle persone
porca vacca
mia madre mi faceva le stesse cose
contro piccolo adesso non più grazie a
dio ho bello a va bene non avevo visto
tizio sto guardando quello sopra che
sembrava va bene cambiando l'ordine
degli addendi il risultato non cambia
avere ragazzi ancora è questo il
contrario invece bellissima e oltre alle
gambe c'è di più questo ebbe questo è
stupendo e questo era veramente figo sua
madre faceva lo stesso sui film di rock
bello il culo a patata al next one siamo
siamo in piscina dove la posso spiegare
questa perché mi vergogno vado avanti o
bello questo un cane che tiene su la
torre di pd gli ha insegnato a falsa
cosa neanche io ci sono riuscito così
bene quando l'ho fatto io che il
problema c'è trova il cane tra i due
anche se sembra tipo closin a cose in
africa cerca porcata mariah poverino più
porta ci vuole che cosa sta facendo sto
cristiano ti sei accorto che lì non c'è
l'acqua vero ci credo non ci sia l'acqua
e non so non sembra un pokémon comunque
stupenda santo di e nessuno gli ha detto
che non bisogna le care le rane e
fantastico nif mai piede
quarto giorno e ancora crede che io sia
suo fratello bellissima stackhouse a
santadi il gatto di gesù madonna che
brutta ma c'è veramente ci hai un letto
con una finestra così zio amica è fatto
per gli esorcismi sta roba santo dio
andiamo avanti
no vabbè non è vero no questo è questo e
un photoshop van dog glielo diciamo che
il ritratto è finito lo lasciamo ancora
così per un po crateri fanno a scassare
i commenti
capita ovviamente tutti i giorni di
accarezzare delle paperelle
mentre la madre ti fotte i soldi la vida
loca
andiamo avanti ragazzi quanto dio ma
questo è un esorcismo sa bambina doveva
sta nel letto di prima non credo che si
stia divertendo penso di no perchè se no
è un problema zio
questa è morta ne sono andate a fuoco i
capelli l'ho capito adesso bello ma la
gente corporate così stupida e qui
esiste foto ne avrò un miliardo mia
madre che mi tirai libri dove l'ha mica
volevo vedere il video è così che nacque
il naso di voldemort il naso di
voldemort tensione e signori signori
marc márquez nella prossima gara su
briaco più lui che lei che le br della
torre di pisa a perfetto nave tranquillo
che 23 drink e sembrano tutte e tre
megan fox quindi non problema ultime
cinque ragazzi allora questa cosa fa
veramente schifo
questo è un genio questa emma watson e
credo sia un p e cos'è quella roba
quando vedi gesù camminare sull'acqua ma
invece ti dai alla break dance e faqih
tutto va dai ragazzi queste erano le
cose le foto tante foto che non erano 20
mango pupazzo doveva assolutamente fare
questo video in ditemi se vi piacciono
tanto sui generi di video sulle immagini
strane che potrei anche pensare di farne
altri però non l'ho mai fatto quindi una
roba un po nuova vero che vi sia
piaciuto ragazzi spero abbiate imparato
come fare breakdance sull'acqua e venti
ragazzi servito vi è piaciuto lasciato
un bel like un bel like anche la pagina
di facebook che come l'invito a tornare
a deliziare sera il city 16 diavolo
prossimo vinto dai ragazzi
[Musica]